si ce ne sont pas des étalons sauvages
quand vos femmes ont suggéré une
thérapie de couple, pensez-vous que
c'est ce qu'elles avaient en tête,
je veux dire que nous sommes un couple de couples qui
facturent assez de délires que vous
n'avez pas
voyagés dans le temps et vous n'avez pas  n'allez pas au paradis et en enfer
voici une vraie idée pour vous être des
modèles pour vos filles
obtenir de vrais emplois
Répondez aux
salutations mes excellents amis, nous avons un
problème,
avancez une chanson créée par Preston
Logan,
jouez ce soir, nous sauverons la réalité telle que nous la
connaissons,
oh mec, nous ferions mieux d'écrire cette chanson maintenant
ou pourquoi ne pouvons-nous pas simplement aller dans le futur
quand nous avons  nous l'avons écrit
et nous le prenons à nous-mêmes, sauf que cela ne
volera pas des acclamations, comment est-ce que
c'est du vol si nous nous le volons mec
[Musique]
mec nos pères sont totalement dans le pétrin
devrait l'aider
[Applaudissements]
pas question comment ça se passe  billy
ted nous rassemblons votre plus
extr  un groupe ordinaire
hé tu veux être dans notre groupe
oh c'est ton fantastique
on va aller parler à la mort est-ce qu'il
joue du scotch tout
seul mec il triche hé la
vie de la mort ce n'est pas un étalon sauvage
allons rock
[Musique]
excellent pour chacun  autre et faire la fête sur les
mecs
[Musique]
comment allez-vous bien vous savez que nous sommes
morts et nous sommes en enfer
mais comment vous
allez